hi I'm Alex Patrick off from Evernote
and I'm a VP for partnerships hi I'm
human girl I'm Android big lead at
evolute hi i'm ty Smith and I'm a senior
android engineered evernote we launched
Evernote in the summer of two thousand
eight we basically figured that nobody
is quite happy with their actual brains
and they really needed something to help
them remember everything that they see
so I wanted to build Evernote to be a
product a nap and the service that will
help you capture anything that's
important to you anywhere you are and
always hope you find it so whenever you
wake up the first device you can reach
with your hand whether it's a phone or a
tablet you should be able to just get to
your important information right away we
want you to use Evernote your whole life
so we're not in a rush to monetize the
application we want people to use it for
free for as long as they want and once
you use it and once you've put a lot of
stuff into it you will see some of the
power features there are premium
features that we charge for let me give
you an example say you've been using
Evernote to store a bunch of documents
one of the premium features that we have
is document search document search lets
us index all of the contents of all of
the office documents you haven't
Evernote and make them searchable so
when I go to search I will see a little
pop-up that says did you know this is a
premium feature and I can buy it right
there directly with the in-app
subscription because Evernote is a long
term product for our users we felt like
the subscription model made the most
sense and when the billing API scheme
out for the different app stores we took
advantage of those as soon as we could
at first we were only able to take
advantage of monthly in-app billing
users would have to resubscribe every
month this had a fairly high turn rate
with sunny or seventy percent with the
rise of subscription models India not
paying api's we seen that reduce down to
near 30 percent on Android which has
been fantastic today Evernote has about
50 million users but seventy percent of
our users come from mobile first but
most people use Evernote on multiple
devices phones tablets PCs and we really
see that Evernote is most useful to
people when you use it across different
devices because you never know which
device you're going to have close to
when we saw the rise of tablets we
really took it very seriously we knew
that Evernote had a huge opportunity to
be an important native app on tap
and we built it early on as best as we
can and we put as much work into the UI
of the tablets as we did in to the
phones or our PC versions and today we
see ourselves as one of the top
productivity apps on every tablet that
there is specifically on the Nexus 7
which is our second most popular device
we've seen a lot of tablet growth
recently so I wanted to walk you through
some of our best practices that we've
discovered on tablet how we gave the
users a great experience we wanted to
give better user experience to or tablet
users so we thought diabetes have to be
more engaging in more power users so we
gave them double patterns and they can
do more stuff at the same time we gave
them a quick and easy way to access
their notebooks their tags places and at
the same time they can see what's
happening with the account and all their
notes our anticipations turned out to be
correct the average session length for
tablet user is almost double that of the
phone user we also anticipated that on
tablet with the larger screen real
estate that we'd see a lot more users
creating content Android is a fastest
growing platform for Evernote so really
excited about what's coming up in the
future and we're working on lots of cool
stuff thank you for watching thank you
thank you